OK.
Moving on to [AUDIO OUT] So good morning to
you who are in other times than me.
Good afternoon to those who are on the east
coast.
I'm Michele Dunn at the National Institute
of Health.
I'd like to welcome you to this second talk
[INAUDIBLE] of the BD2K Guide to the Fundamentals
of Data Science.
Now last week and for the next few weeks,
we're about computing.
So last week's talk [INAUDIBLE], who gave
an overview of the area.
This week, we'll have a narrower topic, but
still at an overview level, a high level 10,000
foot view of the specific topic of workflows
and pipelines.
So we'll hear about what scientific work workflows
and pipelines are and how they will be useful
for even critical to science and big data
management.
Our guest lecturer for today is Dr. Rommie
Amaro, who is a professor of chemistry and
biochemistry at the University of California,
San Diego.
Her research is in computational methods for
drug discovery, where at San Diego, she oversees
a lab that does large scale simulations of
increasingly realistic biological systems
in order to investigate protein function.
She has received many awards, including the
NIH New Innovator Award, as well as a very
prestigious PECASE award.
PECASE stands for the Presidential Early Career
Award for Scientists and Engineers.
Dr. Amaro has received many NHI grants, is
the director or co-director of two very large
NIH awards.
One is for the National Biomedical Computation
Resource, and another is for the Drug Design
Discovery Resource.
In addition, she has received a BD2K R25 award
to build an open educational resource, which
is a couple of MOOCs, as well as a way of
discovering different materials.
So to find out more about that, you can go
to Rommie's website.
You can also go to the Big Data U website
as well.
So please join me in welcoming Dr. Rommie
Amaro for this lecture today.
Rommie.
Thank you, Michelle.
Yes, so I'm very happy to give this lecture
in the BD2K series.
I'm going to be introducing a topic that is
sort of close to my heart as a biomedical
researcher, and that is the topic of workflows
and pipelines in biomedical research.
So just to recap, you just heard an introduction
from Michelle, but I'm a professor of chemistry
and biochemistry at the University of California,
San Diego.
I direct an NIHP41 multi-skilled modeling
resource called the National Biomedical Computation
Resource.
I'll tell you a little bit today about some
of the activities there.
I'm also the codirector of the Drug Design
Data Resource, which is another NIH drug design
methods development, communityoriented resource.
And I think the main thing that I want to
get across in this introduction slide is that
I am a domain scientist, and as
you can tell from my background, I do work,
obviously, in data science.
And there's many very important aspects that
affect what we do.
I'm also a workflow convert, and so what I
want to do in today's seminar is-- because
my understanding is we have a pretty broad
audience in terms of attendees.
So I've tried to make this a pretty general
talk all about workflows and pipelines, so
I'm going to give a broad introduction to
workflows and pipelines.
I'm going to explain why they're both useful
and critical to what many of us are trying
to do in the biomedical research enterprise.
I'll showcase by way of a specific example
in biomedical research how workflows can be
useful for what we're doing and for enabling
reproducible results.
And I will also introduce an example workflow
tool that we've developed at one of my resources,
as well as discuss training opportunities
and additional material for more learning
beyond just the introductory concepts that
I'll speak to today.
So I think probably most everyone knows--
I'm sure on this call-- that it's an extremely
exciting time for computing in biomedical
research, and that's really for a number of
reasons.
One is, of course, that we've had a tremendous
increase in computing power.
And so what I'm showing here is just the increase
in compute power sort of as a function of
time.
And that's been available on the national
supercomputing resources.
So the supercomputing resources are these
large architectures that are available for
academic researchers in the United States
to perform various types of high performance
computing applications.
And biomedical research has certainly benefited
significantly from these resources.
So this is just showing how in the early '90s,
these first computing resources came online.
They had about 12 CPUs, and about every four
to five years since then, we've increased
our computing power by an order of magnitude
taking us to 2015-- 2016-- 2017 now actually,
where we are really right now in what we call
the sustained petaflop performance capabilities.
And that's brought to us by machines like
Titan at Oak Ridge, also Blue Waters at NCSA.
And something very critically important has
been actually the rise in graphical processing
unit technologies, or GPUs, which have really
brought supercomputing to the desktop.
And so a lot of the algorithms that we use
in biomedical computing research actually
port very well to the same architecture used
to develop great graphics for video games.
And so this has really also been a game changer
in a number of ways for biomedical computing.
And then, of course, I think-- I'm sure others
in the series have mentioned that there was
recently-- they've initiated the National
Strategic Computing Initiative, or the NSCI,
in order to bring exascale computing into
reality, hopefully within the next five years
or so.
So just a tremendous increase in computing,
and that's really infiltrated many, many different
aspects, of course not only in biomedical
research, but for the scientific enterprise
generally speaking.
And, of course, it's not just computing, but
it's also data and access to a number of different
types of data, everything from proteomics
and genomics to increasing, amazing increasing
data availability for structural biology at
numerous resolutions, including things from
the structural data for molecular componentry
like in the PDB, as well as macromolecular
complexes thanks to advances in direct detectors
with cryo-electron microscopy and so forth.
And so in terms of what we can do in biomedical
research, trying to bring together all these
different data streams to create new models--
for example, either structural models that
might integrate proteomics, genomics, high
resolution structural biology details as well
as cellular substructure determined with electron
microscopy to bring together to make a multi-modal
multi-scale model.
There's many, many examples of how data is
infiltrating the research enterprise.
And so together, both computing and data are
really transforming how we do research.
And so when we think about how things used
to be, I mean we're not just necessarily doing
one experiment at the bench.
I mean when we're posing a problem or a question
in biomedical research, it's much more than
just one step.
A typical or a state of the art example would
be starting with electron microscopy and all
the terrific advances there in terms of capabilities
and resolution-- for example, with [INAUDIBLE]
complexes.
So we start with our data.
We collect the data at the scope.
We then send that data-- for example, at UC
San Diego on a high speed network over to
a supercomputer.
And I'm just using this as an example here
at San Diego, where we can take the data directly
from the microscopes to the Comet supercomputer
in order to do image processing.
And then once we have that data, we bring--
it's ported again through a high speed network
from the supercomputer into the lab.
And in the lab, we can build and interact
with these data sets using a variety of software,
resources, and develop models and interrogate
them.
We might add additional components to those
models.
For example, from a number of different community
data resources, just there's many different
resources to possibly pull from as you, again,
build and interrogate your model.
And then we might send that new sort of representation
of the data or the method-- we might send
back again to the supercomputers-- for example,
to Blue Waters.
And then we have more data that we process
and return back and can interact with in various
ways.
So this is showing sort of a possibility of
looking at the structures with virtual reality
or other-- sort of more than just three dimensions.
So really where we're at now is how where
experiments, simulation, networking, and expertise
are all combined into a super facility.
But it's really sort of transforming how we
can do biomedical research.
And so the challenge or one major challenge,
when you think about sort of the complicated
end to end scientific discovery process, a
major challenge is the growing complexity
of the computation and data that are required
to solve these highly
specialized significant problems in biomedical
research.
And this complex scientific enterprise really
brings a number of challenges, but one solution
to the growing complexity is the creation
of pipelines and workflows that are able to
assist in the assembly of datasets, as well
as integrate what we call domain-specific
software codes that are able to operate or
execute on various hardware systems or computing
architectures and to do so in a way that is
robust, usable, and reproducible.
And this is really where-- this is really
what's going to be demanded for or what is
currently demanded and will continue to be
demanded for successful biomedical research
projects.
So what is a scientific workflow?
So scientific workflows emerged as an answer
to the need to combine multiple data and computing
components in an automated fashion.
So scientific workflow is really basically
just a series of different computational steps
that scientists use to generate results.
And this may involve accessing multiple different
applications, scientific applications in different
databases, as I mentioned.
Also, it could involve a processing of data.
Most frequently it does using computationally
intensive jobs on various types of computing
platforms, and I'll tell you more about those
with some specific examples.
So the idea is just that it's capturing--
the scientific workflows are really capturing,
again, sort of the complicated many, many
step, end to end experiment, ideally, that
represents a scientific result.
And so even backing off, sort of getting more
simple about it, so really what is a workflow?
And so there's workflows everywhere-- of course,
not just in biomedical research.
So if we just think about when we're trying
to cook something, so I think one analogy
that I sort of like when I'm trying to introduce
the concept of workflows in pipelines to be
very introductory about it is to think about
how one cooks or how one basically cooks.
So when you're trying to create a recipe and
cook food, you have to basically-there's many
steps that you're doing.
You're shopping.
You're preparing the food.
You're cooking it, and you're enjoying it,
eating it, and you're also storing it.
And so each of these steps takes a certain
amount of time, and it's essentially a workflow.
Some of those tasks that have to be performed
might be enjoyable, as sort of is illustrated
here with the beige text.
Some of them might be more tedious or chore-like.
And so one example is like we're making pasta
this evening, so there's all these different
things that we have to do.
It's starting with the shopping for ingredients.
You can see like the raw ingredients on the
left.
You then have to prepare the different ingredients
maybe by chopping and dicing, et cetera.
You then have to cook it, and there might
be multiple things that you need to cook.
And then ultimately, you can serve it, eat
it, and then store it.
So these are all different steps that represent
not a biomedical research workflow-- I'll
get to that-- but just sort of the overall
concept.
And so each of these steps, they take place
in a certain order, and they have a certain
time requirement.
And some of these things need to happen at
the same time as others.
Some of them need to be staged.
Some things can happen in parallel.
Others need to happen in series.
So this is an example that we're all familiar
with.
So we can think about workflows in this context,
even for biomedical research.
And so one thing that we might want-- one
way that workflows can be applicable here
is if you want to speed things up.
So if you're cooking, for example, there are
things that time management can become very
important if you want to actually come up
with a result or a food, a cooked product
at a particular time.
So time management is important, and you can
take advantage of this downtime when you're
working on one element of the recipe.
You can then shift your attention to another
while something-- while, for example, the
pasta is boiling.
And so these recipes can be modified, and
they can be optimized.
And also, similarly, analogously, what if
you have more than one cook?
So can particular jobs be farmed out to different
people, or in this case of automated workflows,
it's to different hardware architectures?
And what can be done at different times or
the same times with multiple participants?
And so one example, again, going back to cooking,
so when we're just starting this, let's say
that we have our vegetables.
And this is something, so we can sort these
vegetables.
And if we have multiple cooks, each cook can
basically be chopping and doing the work on
a certain set of the vegetables.
And then now this would be equivalent to a
map function, where the input are the veggies,
and the chopping is what we would call a userdefined
function.
And the output of this operation would be
chopped groups of each kind of veggies.
This is sort of the food equivalent to the
map function.
Now we have these outputs of these different
piles of veggies.
And we can think about, now we want to bring
them together.
So we have all these different piles.
We want to bring them together.
We bring the tomatoes together, the peppers
together, the onions together.
This is like similar to what we would call
a reduce step.
So here now, the input is having chopped batches
of vegetables for each type, and the equivalent
user-defined function would be to combine
these vegetables basically based on type.
So we can sort them, and then the output is
a bowl of vegetables per veggie kind.
So we can-- again, these are sort of the food
analogies of developing functions and how
you can sort of parse out different jobs to
different people in order to expedite or optimize
what we're doing.
And then we think about when you want make
something more elaborate, not just doing pasta.
We want to make a Thanksgiving dinner.
We have many, many dishes to make.
We may have many helping participants.
Each recipe and so forth has different preparation
time, cooking time, cooling time, et cetera.
So as a chef or as somebody who's organizing
this, you have to think about all these things.
Once you start cooking, what order do you
cook, et cetera, et cetera?
And so this is an example of how we already
use workflow and are really familiar with
them in sort of our just daily life.
And now I'm going to give you some more concrete
examples of how these workflows can be useful,
how workflows can also be useful in science.
So workflows can take a number of different
forms.
They can be, for example, very simple pipelines,
where one example is that you have data on
a normal disk, so you can read and choose
the file.
You can then create a function that basically
does a multiple sequence alignment for you.
And then it outputs that alignment into something
that does a phylogenetic analysis.
And then you can output that out.
It can transfer the output of the phylogenetic
analysis into something where you can actually
visualize it with, for example, using trees
and so forth.
Workflows can also integrate components to
analyze local data.
So this is an example of a workflow drawn
in Kepler, which I'll tell you more about,
for computational flow cytometry data analysis.
So here, it starts to get a little more complicated.
But basically, different components and different
data components can actually come together
to participate in the analysis of data that's
held locally.
We can also use pipelines and workflows to
integrate many different online tools and
several different kinds of databases using
complex programming structures.
So here's an example of a workflow that's
doing some micro array analysis to identify
new candidate target chains.
And here, we start with micro array data.
We do a clustering.
analysis.
We can identify the genes.
We can get them to the sequence retrieval.
We send that back out to the NCBI class search.
It brings back other genomic sequences, and
then we can look for things like promoters
and promoter model generators in order to
generate a consensus sequence, which be put
back onto the BLAST search and then, again,
to finally identify a new candidate target
gene.
So this is a more sort of elaborate example
of how workflows can be used to integrate
a number of different online tools, as well
as online databases in order to help facilitate
biomedical research.
Workflows can also have concurrent analysis
and data management steps that actually are
distributed to different computing platforms.
And so this is an example that I will speak
much more about when I give a concrete example.
But here, we can actually-- what this workflow
is doing is actually one of the sort of what
we call actors or modules in this workflow
is actually being used to distribute or to
sort of spawn out many different jobs in parallel
on an HPC platform.
And then the analysis on each of those can
come back asynchronously or synchronously
in order to determine the results of the jobs.
Of course, workflows can also integrate cloud
resources.
So they can tie into and connect to not just
local data, but data that can be in the cloud
or other places.
So overall, biomedical research workflows
allow us to assemble
complex processes easily, transparently access
different computing resources, which is increasingly
important as computing enters more and more
elements of biomedical research enterprise.
It allows us to automate it in more rigorous
fashion, incorporate multiple software tools,
and I'll talk more about also why that's so
important, again, in the example I'll show
you.
They also help enable reproducibility, which,
of course, we all know is a major challenge
for science in general, but also for biomedical
research-- how we can ensure that when we
have one student or multiple students working
on a project, that then when those students
leave, and new ones come in, that the protocols
are being followed correctly and that we really
knew how we get generated the model, but in
a very specific kind of way that it's really,
truly useful.
And of course, the best research workflows
will really build around a community development
model, and this is something that I think
many fields are now-- many subfields within
biomedical research are really embracing.
And that's the idea that so I can develop
workflows in my lab and share them very easily
with colleagues and with the community, and
we can use each other's efforts to build,
again, and use these sort of more elaborate,
reproducible frameworks for science.
And so there are many scientific workflow
systems, as one would imagine.
This is something that people have been working
on for at least two decades.
So one of the earliest scientific workflow
systems was something called DiscoveryNet.
And then there were a whole bunch like Triana,
Pegasus, Kepler, Taverna, Pipeline Pilot coming
on in the early 2000s.
KNIME is another very popular workflow system.
We have Vistrails, GenePattern, so you can
see sort of the evolution of these through
about 2010.
And what I am going to mostly talk about today
in the concrete examples is a workflow system
called Kepler.
This is, again, a very popular common workflow
framework.
It has a diverse library of scientific components
and use cases.
It allows transparent support for multiple
workflow engines, so you can actually connect.
So even within a Kepler workflow, you can
actually call other workflow systems-- for
example, like KNIME-- in order to execute
an end to end process.
And it's used by many communities, not just
in biomedical research, but also in fire detection
and all sorts of things.
So it's been a useful community development
tool.
So that's the one that I'll mostly focus on
today, but I just also mention, of course,
that there are many different programs, and
a lot of them have strengths and weaknesses.
I'm sure many other learning opportunities
if you want to dig in on the details of these
other workflow systems.
So how do I use workflows, and how did I come
to sort of seeing a light with how useful
they can be and how important they actually
are to the scientific enterprise?
So this example I'm going to tell you about
is one that's in my domain of expertise, which
is computer-aided drug discovery.
So the work that I do in my lab and that we
do in some of my resources actually involves
the computational modeling of atomic level
systems in biomedicine.
And so we'd like to think one of the major
approaches we use is something called molecular
dynamic simulations.
And I'm showing here a picture of a computational
microscope, so this was sort of a phrase coined
by Klau Schulten, which basically is sort
of we're trying to use these computers, the
HPC computers mainly, but now actually, it's
evolved into using also GPU architectures.
We're trying to use these methods to gain
additional insight into these molecular systems
that we sometimes cannot access with experiments
alone.
And so what these simulations involve, so
basically we're representing all the atoms
of our system.
We're representing them at the atomic level,
and so we define what we call a potential
function, which you can see there.
So every two atoms that are connected form
a bond.
Every three atoms that are connected form
an angle.
Every four atoms are in dihedrals and torsions.
And each of these terms, each of these elements
of the system actually has a term in a potential
function.
And then we're basically using physics.
We're just simply integrating it into the
equation of motion over time in order to build
up a dynamical trajectory of the time-dependent
dynamics of our system.
So we're basically representing these molecular
level systems numerically and trying to determine
the wiggling and jiggling of the atoms, if
you will.
And so these experiments use a number of different
community developed tools like NAMD, AMBER,
many different tools, actually.
And the engine that this microscope runs on
are basically the supercomputing platforms,
and now graphical processing units, and also
sometimes local desktops and so forth.
But they can run in many places.
So one of the major goals that we had it in
my lab was to try to use simulation in early
stage drug discovery.
And what I'm showing on the let is and old
napkin sketch from, actually, when I was a
post-doc.
And we were just sort of like walking through
how we could use the output of the simulations,
which as I mentioned, is just sort of the
wiggling and jiggling or the time-dependent
dynamics of these molecules, how we could
use this in computeraided drug design.
And so it's really-- you can see this sort
of like chicken scratch.
And over the course of some years, we were
able to actually develop methods that would
be gainfully used to incorporate simulation
in drug discovery.
And so what that would mean is so you can
see that I'm advancing-- the concept here
of the workflow is advancing.
And this is sort of like I think a normal
way for-- this is a very sort of natural,
normal way for scientific methods and projects
to evolve.
First, you start with an idea that's literally
a sketch on the back of a napkin, and you
work on it.
You keep working
on it, and then you get the first prototype.
And then you can continue to elaborate.
And ultimately, what I'll show you many slides
down the road is that we've gone from basically
the napkin-type drawing to really a hardened
workflow product.
And so why do we care?
So just in case there are some scientists
out there, I'm going to give you a little
bit of science in addition to the computing.
So one successful example of this involves
P53, which is the guardian of the genome.
So P53 is a protein that's-- a transcription
factor that's mutated in over 50% of all human
cancers.
And so it's a molecule that senses-- basically,
when the cell has some type of damage like
DNA breaks or UV irradiation, P53 should sense
that damage and then regulate pathways related
to programmed cell death like growth of Ras
and apoptosis and prevention of [INAUDIBLE].
And so what happens in over 60% of human cancers
is that P53 is mutated, and it's inactive.
And so these tumors just proliferate.
And so we were very interested in trying to
understand what was going on there, how the
destabilization worked, et cetera.
And a longstanding dream of cancer biologists,
actually, was to try to basically reactivate
the cancerous or inactive P53 with small molecules.
And so the idea would be that we would have
a cancer mutant that has this inactive P53.
You would bind some drug to it, and you would
reactivate it.
And then those cells that formerly were just
proliferating and metastasizing, that they
would reengage their programmed cell death
and die.
And so there were a number of compounds that
had been found over the years after about
20 years of research.
They had found a handful of compounds, but
they didn't know exactly how they worked.
And so we began doing molecular dynamic simulations
of this target in order to try to figure out--
again, we're interested in looking at the
dynamics, because we had known that actually
it was quite a flexible protein.
So this is the output of a molecular dynamic
simulation.
You can see all the atoms wiggling and jiggling.
And what I want to bring your attention to
is this area in the middle, where we have
a-- I don't know if you can see my cursor.
But there's a cysteine residue here in a pocket,
where you see a lot of mobility.
And so what was really interesting from a
scientific perspective was that if you looked
at the PDB database, there's over 100 different
structures of P53, and they all have the same
sort of architecture around that particular
cysteine, which is actually-- it's sort of
like tucked away in back, sort of a closed
pocket.
And so what we see in the computational simulations
is actually the formation of an open pocket
around this residue.
And this is very intriguing, because we found
this new site, and we also saw that it might,
perhaps, actually druggable, so we performed
small molecule docking into that site.
And basically, using the work-- so here's
sort of just a sketch of the workflow for
virtual screening, where we can take these
protein or receptor structures.
And this could be coming from the PDB database
with x-ray crystallography.
It could also be simulation
data from the molecular dynamic simulations.
We have another database of ligands.
In this example, we're using the NCI diversity
set.
We bring them together using AutoDock Vina,
so this is another procedural operation.
We then do what's called post-processing,
and then we pass our predictions to our experimental
collaborators for testing.
With this workflow, we were able to find one
reactivation molecule called stictic acid,
and our collaborator showed that it there
was dose-dependant rescue in mammalian cancer
cells.
But one of the really interesting things also
was that in addition to finding a new compound,
we were able to rationalize the mechanism
of action for one of the formerly discovered
compounds that's actually in clinical trials.
So this was really exciting.
Then we wanted to scale it up.
And by scaling up, we really wanted to be
able to screen against many, many more compounds,
and also to do sort of much more sophisticated
post-processing with regard to ranking of
compounds.
And one way this was enabled was through workflows.
And so with this sort of more automated pipeline--
so this I'll just call a pipeline, because
it's really just showing sort of like the
procedural steps of what we're doing.
We were able to discover many more compounds
in a very short amount of time-- basically
in six months-- than in all the research efforts
of the previous 20 years combined.
So once we were able to scale it, and with
a good model, the discovery really sort of
took off.
And so what we were able to do is really go
from what was just a chicken scratch pipe
dream to sort of pipeline to now a scalable,
automated workflow.
And so what does that mean?
So when we were doing these experiments that
I was telling you about here, this is really--
as many people in research will do and in
computational biomedical research I'm sure,
but in many other fields also, again when
you're developing a prototype, very often
what happens is you have a post-doc or a student,
who has a set of scripts.
And they're running these scripts, and sometimes
these scripts can be quite elaborate.
But there's many, many steps involved in this
workflow, everything from selection of the
structures that you're inputting into MD to
the creation of the molecular dynamics model,
running of the trajectories, selecting the
structures, how you process the ligands, how
you're doing the docking.
There are so many things that one really needs
to keep track.
And we do our best.
I think everybody-- all biomedical researchers
try to do their best in terms of keeping very
careful lab notebooks, digital notebooks,
saving the scripts, and so on and so forth.
And that gets us pretty far, but it still
has significant-- it still has significant
limitations.
And I'll talk about some of those limitations
and how workflows can help us get around those.
So what we did was actually to develop-- using
the Kepler workflow system, we were able to
develop a scalable, automated workflow.
So we would basically have-- we would be able
to, in this one example, we would have all
those small molecules that we wanted to screen
against.
We put those in a directory, and this Kepler
workflow would see this directory.
It would go into the contents, and then actually
perform a series of steps that were what we
call parameterized ligands, which is getting
them ready for molecular dynamics.
We can then simulate them and then do processing.
And each one of these-- so this little box
here, this ligand parameterization, is actually
represented by-- if you actually dig into
this one task, it's actually many subtasks.
And this is really how it is for many different
steps in biomedical research.
So when we take-- instead of using scripts
for this anti-chamber step and this Gaussian
step and so forth, we can actually encode
it into a workflow, such that all we have
to do is have a directory of ligands.
And then everything else just flows.
As the output finishes, it flows to the next.
It flows to the next.
And everything about it is tracked.
Again, I'll tell you more about that.
So all the software versions, all of like
when you actually ran the jobs, all the library
dependencies, it can all be tracked through
something called provenance.
And so when we recapitulate these very complex
end to end experiments into these automated
workflows, it brings tremendous benefit, including
increased reuse, because it's much easier,
generally speaking, for a new student or post-doc
to pick up and run these automated workflows
if they don't have to stitch together a bunch
of loose scripts.
It increases reproducibility, because we've
now really tracked everything and all of the
dependencies with provenance.
It helps us scale execution both of the problem
and the solution.
So I'll talk a little bit more about scaling
of execution.
So that just essentially means that we can
more easily connect to different computing
resources in order to carry out the job, and
it makes it easy to compare methods.
So if you just want to really change only
one thing, you can just go in and change one
parameter inside one box and rerun it and
compare.
And it also makes it significantly easier
to train students, because now they see, when
they sit down for the first time, they can
see the whole pipeline and dig in on each
module in a way that is simplified.
So just one of the steps that we carried out
in the very complicated end to end process
of small molecule discovery, one of the processes,
as I mentioned, was just running molecular
dynamic simulations.
And so we've worked to develop, again, a workflow
tool using Kepler that just carries out AMBER,
what we call AMBER molecular dynamics.
So AMBER is an MD engine that's available
broadly to the community.
And we've developed now a workflow tool that
just allows people to carry out research quality,
molecular dynamic simulations using AMBER
GPU processing technology and the Kepler workflow
system.
And so these are, again, sort of a very high
level representation of different steps that
we have to do in order to carry out molecular
dynamics.
And so if we look in this one step of something
we call minimization, if you actually
zoom into this minimization box, there's many
steps.
It's not just one step for minimization.
There's actually five different minimization
steps.
And so what this tool does again is in an
automated fashion, sort of feed from-- as
the first minimization step finishes, then
the output feeds into the second step and
so on and so forth.
And then the outputs from minimization go
to a stage we call heating, and then to equilibration.
And again, in equilibration, you can see it's
multistage.
And then when we get to production, one interesting
thing here is that you see that there's all
these different little outputs, so it's going--
basically, when we go to production, instead
of just running on one GPU, we actually scale
it out to multiple GPUs in parallel.
And so this workflow tool basically allows
the researchers to do that very, very easily.
And then so it also has sort of a graphical
user interface for users.
And so again, sort of the molecular dynamics
workflow, you can actually-- users can go
into each of these little boxes.
And at the base level they can go in and edit
the key parameters.
Different parameters can be exposed or hidden
depending on-- because some parameters, as
people know in various programs, basically
maybe never change.
Others, you have to change depending on your
system.
So this can be configured, so we configured
it for molecular dynamics using sort of best
practices for the community, but this can
be-- different levels of detail can be hidden
or revealed depending on the application.
And then we can, in terms of where the simulations
actually run, they have different options.
You can have local execution options.
You can run on a local cluster, or you can
also port out to, for example, the exceed
computing resources like Gordon or Comet.
And so
the gray circle here is just sort of showing
all the different types of heterogeneous computing
resources that these workflows can connect
to.
And that includes, for example, operating
in the Amazon cloud.
And even within one workflow, you can have
many different computational architectures
engaged.
That's one of the advantages of Kepler is
that if I have one step that needs to run
on my local GPU, it can just do that.
But it can also route to NSF resources or,
again, the cloud or any sort of computing
architecture.
So we can have multiple architectures engaged
within one single workflow.
OK.
So we're getting to the-- we're 40 minutes
in.
So how does one even start conceptualizing
a computational workflow?
Well, in general, we would advice to start
with the workflow as a black box.
And so just treat the whole workflow as a
black box, and you'd have to think of, what
is the use case and application?
So what is the real science question that
this workflow is solving?
So you're going to have here some input data,
and then you're going to have some process.
And this is just shown as one giant black
box, but it's sometimes many, many steps.
And then you have to think about what your
output is going to be.
And then you have to conceptualize.
Then you really need to dig into, well, what
are my steps?
So in terms of cooking, this is things like
if I'm working on a pie, I have to put the
ingredients together, cook and chill it, et
cetera, bake turkey, make the side dishes.
So this would be for Thanksgiving dinner all
the things you need to do.
For a scientific application, this might be
things like you've got to collect the data,
the [INAUDIBLE] data.
You have to do the sequence alignment, et
cetera.
And so you basically treat each step like
a workflow, like a mini workflow.
So you want to basically try to reach what
we would call, I guess, an atomic functional
step.
So you really-- when you think about all these
things, you have to find the data, access
the data.
Maybe you have to move the data, and then
once you have the data, it has to be cleaned,
possibly integrated.
Maybe you need to divide it up or pre-process
it.
And then you get into actually running the
jobs if you have like, for example, simulations.
You are processing it, generating data, processing
data, and analyzing data.
And then if you get into data interpretation
and so forth, where you're going to interpret
the results, come back, do visualization,
and so forth.
And so going back to our cooking analogy,
we sort of had the shopping stage, the preparing
stage, the cooking stage, and the storing
stage.
And so questions that one wants to ask is
definitely where and how do you get the data?
What format is the data in?
How can you actually integrate or subset data
sets?
And then, of course, how you analyze the data.
What is the analysis function?
What are the different parameters that are
needed to customize each step?
Et cetera.
And I will say that when you have an end to
end-- when you have a complex workflow or
experiment, it's challenging to do this.
And it requires a lot of time and a lot of
thought, but ultimately, these are the kind
of things that will enable truly reproducible
science.
And I think one of the great things about
workflows is that once you do this work of
really analyzing and this detail and putting
things together and standardizing the process,
the data and the process, you then have a
tool.
And that also becomes-- that sort of conceptualization
of the data itself is actually very valuable.
In terms of the steps for searching for the
data, of course, you need to know what you're
looking for at first, so different data formats,
and the meaning of the data, how it actually
scientifically and conceptually relates to
the analysis that you're doing.
And then it helps if you, of course, for you
to know exactly where you need to find that
data, so where to find what you're looking
for.
And here, I'm sure there will be other talks
in the series, where some of these data sources
are discussed in more detail.
But there's many surgical data archives and
repositories, and people are working very
hard to make sure these are standardized with
correct data ontologies and metadata standards
and so forth.
And anyway, the data could also, for example,
be coming from your own sensor networks or
other scientific instruments, even just in
your own lab.
Another important component that needs to
be considered in general in the scientific
enterprise, but also with workflows, is do
you have to move data?
Sometimes you do need to move data, and then
depending on how big it is, that could be
a problem.
And maybe you need to come up with different
ways to access the data so that you don't
have to move it.
But in any case, it's just to note that moving
data can sometimes, of course, be a big challenge,
especially very large data sets, and it's
something to think about and to try to avoid,
I would say, at all costs if you can help
it.
So there's various different access technologies
also that can be used if data moving is needed.
Again, I guess I sort of already covered this,
but we have the ability-- one of the great
things about developing these workflows is
that once you have them developed, we say
Kepler-- it's actually not that difficult
to change where you are executing the jobs,
the data generation jobs with the analysis
and processing.
And so you can move around to different computing
resources depending on the requirements of
your job.
And for example, some steps may be more memory
intensive.
Some may be more compute intensive.
Some may port very well to GPUs.
You can be flexible about that, and you should
be so that you can really gainfully take advantage
of as much-- so you can get as much advantage
as you can of the different resources.
And then, as I mentioned, once you do the
work of building the workflow, you build it
once, and it is a lot of work to build it.
But then you can run it many times, and you
have terrific possibilities for reuse.
So hopefully, the same workflow will support
your computational experimental work and dynamic
scalability on many different platforms.
And the scalability can be based on a number
of different data features like data volume
and velocity.
This could change depending on those aspects
of it.
Maybe you might need to change something about
the modeling based on different optimization
criteria, and then also, of course, these
workflows, once you build them, you can run
them many times, but you can also alter it
based on changes in network storage and computing
availability.
And so these are tweaks that can be made.
And then one of my favorite parts really of
the workflow, I have to say, is the saving
and sharing of the reports and final products
with your team and collaborators and with
the broader community.
So computational data science is right in
the middle of bridging the gap between the
data that is generated and really the key
scientific insight.
And so bringing everything together in a workflow
and in a scalable automated workflow like
I showed you with Kepler
is something that can be tremendously powerful.
And so I think another sort of aspect of this
is that people should, they can and they should
use whatever favorite tools or programs you
need to answer the question to implement the
methods in your workflow.
There's no reason to feel that you need to
be limited.
I think really the possibilities are almost
endless in terms of different possibilities
to enumerate within your own scientific domain.
And then the great thing is that the process
itself is shareable, so you have-- when you
build these workflows, they themselves are
their own sort of data structure.
And you can exchange them.
Communities, of course, are working very hard
to standardize them.
Again, as I've mentioned multiple times, they're
scalable.
And it helps-these workflows also help enable
really sort of accountable science.
So again, sort of not to beat a dead horse,
I guess is what they would say, but these
scientific experiments involve many different
kinds of data coming from different sources,
and there's different versions.
This is the other thing that has driven us
crazy is how you can run a particular program--
for example, docking program one day on one
particular architecture, and then there's
some update that's made, and now it's version
5.7 instead of 4.2.
And maybe it didn't break any of the scripts
that you used as input, but maybe it changed
the results because of something.
And it's possible sometimes that trainees
and researchers don't necessarily know the
fine, fine detail of what's going on, especially
for people who are domain scientists and who
are pulling together 20 different tools in
one biomedical experiment.
And so one of the great things about these
workflows is that a lot of that versioning
and dependencies and everything, it can be
recorded through something called provenance
and tracked and then reported and stored so
that people really know exactly what was happening
at what given time, and you can refollow that
data flow.
And, of course, so that's just on the data
and the execution side, but you can really
very clearly see and document what processes
ran in which order, which steps actually depended
on the output from the previous step, which
could just run in parallel separately, which
libraries were used, and also who generated
what.
So if you have collaborators, it's a very
good way to sort of share everything.
And so provenance is something that I know
has been talked about already more technically
for sure in the BD2K series.
But basically, for those who haven't heard
it, provenance basically is something that
helps tremendously with what we call research
accountability and reproducibility.
It's basically, according to Wikipedia that
would define it as the chronology of ownership,
custody, or location of the historical object.
So when we think about provenance in terms
of workflows, this is really sort of like
digital notebook, but on steroids.
It actually can contain different information
depending on what you said, so it can be configured
to retain particular aspects of the experiment
that you think are important, but it can capture
everything-- inputs, outputs,
particular aspects of the experiment that
you think are important, but it can capture
everything-- inputs, outputs, intermediate
results, all the work, the parameters and
details of the different components of the
workflows, so all those different actors or
boxes, which I showed you, all the steps,
how the steps are linked together, all the
different parameters.
This can actually be recorded in with data
provenance or with these provenance elements.
And this is useful, because it keeps the association.
It retains the association of results of the
particular workflow to processes.
It also makes it easier to validate and regenerate
results and processes, because you know exactly
how you got them in the first place.
It's much more easy-- it's much easier to
compare different workflow versions, do parameter
optimizations, et cetera, and sometimes some
of these programs actually allow you to do
sort of intelligent or facilitated reruns
and failure recovery.
So different questions you can ask with provenance
or different questions that are answered with
provenance, for example-- you can find out
how long did this particular workflow run
take.
What parameter values were used?
What different components or processes or
actors does the workflow have?
How long does one particular actor take?
So how long is one step?
Where's my bottleneck?
And what workflows did a specific user run
on a given date?
These are all questions that one can dig in
on.
And so again, there's many reasons why you
might want to share workflows.
For example, if you're doing collaborative
research, if you want to just inform people
of progress or formalize application development,
et cetera.
And also for publications, I think one of
the also movements that we're trying to catalyze,
at least in the molecular dynamics community,
which is challenged with-- suffers like many
areas with reproducibility.
We can actually publish-- along with our scientific
paper, we can publish these workflow protocols.
And hopefully, we're trying to develop a community
of researchers, who are developing these.
And so we can all be ensured that we are really
performing research in a transparent reproducible
way for the maximal gain for the community.
And so when you're sharing workflow results,
there's different ways that you can share
workflows.
With versioning, for example, you can use
GitHub to do that.
There's also cloud file hosting services,
so you can share workflows using Dropbox,
Google Drive, et cetera.
And then the other thing that we also do,
and I think a lot of others have taken to
sort of recently is to create iPython notebooks
that share execution history, input parameters,
and results.
So there's many different ways that workflows
can come into the enterprise, and certainly,
sharing of the results is super important.
So I only have five minutes, and I want to
at least leave a couple minutes for questions
in case there are any.
But before I leave, I wanted to say I know
this was a very high level introduction to
workflows and pipelines for biomedical researchers.
So if you want to get more information, of
course, Google is your friend.
But I'll just give you a couple of leads,
so one place where you can get some hands-on
experience, you can go to biobigdata.ucsd.edu.
There's a scalable-- so there is a Kepler
class or course there is-- it should be very
easy for people to run.
It comes with a virtual machine that you can
have everything, all the data and everything
you need installed and lectures.
You can actually go to this site and retrieve
that information and actually go through the
course.
And if you want to see-- the first course
is just on the Kepler software framework.
If you want to see an actual application of
how workflows can come into biomedical research,
we also have a class that we call Data to
Structural Models that walks through image
analysis and segmentation for electron tomography.
And it applies a Kepler workflow for image
segmentation and analysis.
And so you can get in a sort of more domain-specific
example there.
And of course, also, I need to give a shout
out to ERuDIte and the BD2K training coordinating
center.
They also-- I just very quickly searched for
workflows in ERuDIte, and you can see that
there's 22 different results and a number
of different people who will show and talk
about examples that highlight workflows in
biomedical research.
And I do have an acknowledgement slide.
Of course, I just want to thank the BD2K efforts,
the NIH generally, my groups.
Ilkay Altintas actually is my collaborator,
co-PI on the BD2K R25 award for the biomedical
big data training collaborative, and she's
a major developer of Kepler and has been a
terrific resource for information on workflows
and pipelines.
So I think I have like two minutes.
I would love to take questions if there's
any questions.
Thank you.
That was a fabulous talk.
There are a few questions.
Great.
I'll combine a couple of them.
This one is about sharing of data, and you
mentioned a couple of different options-FTP
and [INAUDIBLE].
Are there any others?
Does internet too improve the transfer rates?
Is there any advice you can give about that?
Speak to-- yes.
I will say that in general, we try to avoid
moving data, but of course, we do have to
move some.
And that's a very good question.
I know that there are-- other than the examples
that I showed, this is a tough one for me
to answer.
Yeah.
We generally try to avoid moving huge data
sets.
When we do, we just use sort of like the normal
protocols.
But definitely, I'm sure that there are many
people who are working on more effective and
efficient ways to actually transfer data.
One thing that we've done too to try to avoid
transferring data, of course, is to try to
work on other technologies like remote visualization
and so forth.
That's sort of been one of our major efforts.
So thank you.
I think moving the computation and the visualization
to the data is what is more common now or
what will be even more common in the future.
So one more question.
What do you think about the common workflow
language, and does Kepler support CWL?
That's another very good question.
I wish Ilkay was here to answer that.
I'm pretty sure it does.
I think common-- I generally think common
workflow language is going to be a good move
for the community.
I don't know when we have actually the hard
stop here.
I do believe it does support it, but I'm not
sure exactly to what extent it does.
I do think we need to stop now, but thank
you very much, Rommie.
This was a wonderful talk, and we really appreciate
you coming here and sharing your expertise
with us.
It was fun.
Thanks.
OK.
Goodbye.
Thank you all.
See you next week.